Harry Potter is a franchise that's no
stranger to video game adaptations ever
since 2001 there have been a slew of
game releases coinciding with the
release of the films and Beyond however
for the most part these games have
focused exclusively on the story of the
Harry Potter books rather than the world
itself Hogwarts Legacy finally sets out
to right that wrong as an open world
action RPG that doesn't star Harry
Potter and with it releasing shortly
here is everything you need to know
about Hogwarts Legacy
foreign
developments on Hogwarts Legacy began as
far back as at least 2017 by Avalanche
software and the game is being published
by Warner Brothers games Avalanche
software used to be owned by Disney so
their prior roster of recent games
mostly consists of Disney licenses such
as Disney Infinity The Game's director
Alan 2 is an industry veteran whose work
goes as far back as working on Starcraft
brood Wars as an artist and designer
Hogwarts Legacy takes place in the late
1800s prior to the Harry Potter books
and films and back when Phineas
nigellous black was Headmaster of
Hogwarts phineas's serious black
Bellatrix Lestrange and Narcissa
Malfoy's great great grandfather readers
of the books might recall that phineas's
portrait would leak information about
Harry Ron and Hermione to Snape via his
portrait at Hogwarts Phineas is being
played by Simon Pegg and notably he
doesn't care too much about the position
of Headmaster but rather took the job
purely for The Prestige of it another
professor during this era is actually a
Weasley the character you play as is a
late fifth year student who's just now
starting at Hogwarts and has to
therefore play catch up to the rest as
you're behind the ministry of magic has
loaned to you a magical Field Guide to
help you catch up to the other students
which presents you with ways to learn
and grow all around you that said your
character has a unique ability to
interact with powerful ancient magic
hidden in The Wizarding World you'll
need to discover why this ancient magic
has returned who's behind it and who
wants to utilize its power to destroy
Wizarding kind there are rumors of a
mounting Goblin rebellion and part of
your journey will involve you working
alongside the accomplished Professor fig
to look into this these goblins have
Allied themselves with powerful dark
Wizards
combat consists of equipping a number of
spells in the designated slots and using
these in combination with basic shots
and other tools at your disposal I'll be
outlining later R2 will shoot out a
basic shot which is basically that Zap
Attack you see a lot in the later Harry
Potter films meanwhile holding R2 lets
you then choose one of your more
advanced spells from the slottable spell
diamond using a face button notably you
can gain three additional spell diamonds
throughout the game which will
eventually allow you to have a total of
16 slottable spells you can quickly
access during combat by cycling through
them with your d-pad while you can use
the basic R2 shot repeatedly each of the
slottable Spells has a cool down period
with the more advanced the spell the
longer the cooldown period before you
can use it again the basic shot does
minimal damage but is still good for
juggling enemies to set up Combos and
while you're waiting for your major
spells cooldowns to end when facing
other Wizards you won't be the only one
who can cast protego to Shield yourself
or have the ability to deflect attacks
however to help with this colors are
handily split into types of spell by
color and when you see a shield around a
fellow wizard it immediately indicates
which color or type of spell will break
their Shield a Halo will appear around
the character's head just before an
enemy is about to attack if you see this
and it's yellow you'll be able to
deflect the enemy's attack with a
specific face button assigned to do this
on a PS5 the default button is triangle
by holding the triangle button in these
instances rather than just deflecting it
you'll also counter-attack with Stupify
which you can use towards the enemy who
is attacking or a different enemy you
may be in the middle of comboing that
said there are also going to be
unblockable spells which will indicate
on the player via a red halo those
you'll have to dodge out of the way from
it seems based on the trailers you'll
also get a certain number of iframes
during the middle of this role iframes
being invincibility frames were for a
small portion of time nothing can hurt
you if that is the case Souls fans
Rejoice you'll be well prepped for this
while there are the normal spells Harry
Potter fans will likely be very familiar
with at this point there's also special
ancient magic spells players will be
able to utilize the way this ancient
magic manifests itself depends on the
enemy you're fighting and as their
devastating attacks there's a special
meteor you'll have to fill up with in
combat this meter fills up through
combos which will also in turn help make
enemies drop Blue Magic the player can
run and pick up which will also refill
the ancient magic meter Beyond magic
players will also be able to brew and
equip special tools to help in combat
this could be a rock Skin Potion that
just like it sounds covers the player's
skin and rocks and reduces damage from
enemies while it's active there's a wig
and weld potion which is your standard
Health restoration potion or even a
focus potion which increases how quickly
your cooldowns wear off Beyond brewing
potions you can equip and add as a tool
you can also add plants to your tool set
such as a Chinese chopping cabbage which
attacks nearby enemies after you release
it or perhaps a venomous tentacula which
which when deployed shoots acid at
nearby enemies and acts similar to a
turret you can use a mandrake which will
stun enemies after you pull it out
you'll also be able to use the items
around you to lift and toss at enemies
which of course includes the classic
video game exploding Barrel the talent
system in the game will also affect your
spells in combat however so far the
details on this are fairly unknown at
least to my knowledge there are two
combat Arenas within the base game Each
of which has you fight off ways of
enemies in order to unlock Cosmetics for
your character there's also a specific
battle arena tied with the dark ass pack
the dark arts battle arena this Arena
can be found within the Forbidden Forest
unfortunately this arena is tied to a
special dark arts pack and only comes
with the deluxe or digital Deluxe
editions of the game players who
purchase the standard edition will have
to buy the dark arts pack separately
each battle arena has a specific set of
spells you're only allowed to equip with
in the arena and various optional
dueling Feats you'll want to accomplish
as an example of the Spells the dark
arts Arena will let you equip and use
the three unforgivable curses you'll be
able to utilize these spells here even
if you haven't unlocked them yet in the
main game which might be a good way for
goody two shoes Gryffindor like me to
finally have some fun with the Wizarding
world's gun Avada Kedavra and speaking
of which for the most part it sounds
like Avada Kedavra will work just like
it does in Harry Potter as an instant
death spell the developers showed this
in action within the combat Arena and
sure enough insta death to the enemy
Avada Kedavra as well as the other
unforgivable curses our spells players
will be able to unlock and add to their
repertoire within normal combat in the
outside world you'll also be able to use
stealth to try and get the upper hand
including the invisibility spell
disillusionment enemies will be able to
hear sounds and come to investigate them
which is where disillusionment
especially comes in handy granted it's
not total invisibility like the
invisibility cloak was
starting from the beginning the game
includes a fairly robust character
creator while there are some initial
presets you can choose from there the
team allows you to go into a little more
detail with how your character looks
from facial shape to Hair Choice and
allows you to choose if you're a Witcher
wizard however I didn't notice any
in-depth sliders from what I've seen if
you don't like the choices you've made
you'll be able to change certain
elements later on such as hair color and
style at a barber shop type place in
hogsmead however you will be locked into
your body and face
it's unclear how you'll be sorted into
one of the four houses as of yet but you
don't get to choose that during the
Character Creator the game's HUD
contains a spell diamond on the bottom
right with slottable spells you'll be
able to quickly conjure a d-pad icon
showing your essential spells that are
always attached to your controller such
as a reveal or a spell slotting menu a
green bar on the bottom right
representing your health with a potion
next to it to quickly show how many
potions you have a bar above for your
combo meter a map and a compass on the
far left and next to that on the left an
equipped magical tool and how you access
your tool menu throughout the school
you'll also be able to use reveillo or
other spells to find Field Guide Pages
which is one of the many optional
challenges that you'll be accomplishing
throughout the game the Wizards Field
Guide is something given to you early on
in the game and is how you work on
catching up with the other students as
you're a fifth year student who has for
some reason just now enrolled at
Hogwarts in fact the pause menu is your
Field Guide some of the various
challenges contained within include the
aforementioned finding of Field Guide
pages combat challenges quests
exploration and deal with the room of
requirements on the topic of the room of
requirements it has been transformed
into space for preparing all kinds of
things for your journey you can
personalize it to make it feel like your
own and while I'd love to hang
Dumbledore Army Flyers everywhere I'm
not planning on going into divination so
you know probably not something you can
add what you can do though is completely
change the architecture via magic such
as changing the ceiling from a boring
scientific ceiling to a beautiful
botanic ceiling I don't know why you'd
ever choose the scientific ceiling but
that's just me you can also conjure
various objects into the space that can
make it feel like home like rugs statues
ornaments or Furniture these
conjurations can be obtained by
purchasing conjuration recipes from
hogsmead or from various quests in the
game more importantly from a gameplay
perspective you can also conjure
planting pots and potion stations where
you can grow plants and Brew Your
potions this is where you'd bring your
gear and by bringing it to a loom in the
room of requirements you can add a
certain number of traits to your gear
based on Trace that you've collected and
how many Trace loss that gear has these
trades consist of things like protego
shielding which decreases damage you
take from dark Wizards or Goblin silver
resistance which on the other hand
decreases damage you take from goblins
for those of you focused on fashion
Potter you'll be able to change the look
of the gear you collect to look like
other gear so if you collect something
super powerful but hate the way it looks
no worries you can go ahead and apply
another look to it you'll also not
necessarily know what the gear you
collect as immediately upon getting it
and there's an identification station
inside the room of requirement for
finding out which is one of the first
things you'll be unlocking Additionally
the remove requirement has a vivarium
which has a massive space on the inside
a la Newt scamander's suitcase filled
with magical beasts from here you can
take care of the various beasts you
rescue from poachers or other situations
and presumably collect by petting them
playing with them with a collection of
toys and feeding them in return you'll
receive magical ingredients from them
which you can use on your gear you can
also conjure and personalize the
vivarium to make the perfect home for
your beasts and name the various beasts
within Hogwarts you'll be sorted into
either Gryffindor Slytherin Ravenclaw or
Hufflepuff and have access to your
dormitory including the never before
seen visually Hufflepuff dorm all of
these have their own unique common room
music for each house you'll be able to
find fast travel points as the school is
so massive the house hourglasses for
school points are of course also present
here notably these house points aren't a
gameplay mechanic of the game but
instead related to the story there are
several quests you can stumble across
and some of these can be given by fellow
students which sometimes come across as
gossip that you'll want to look into or
perhaps even from teachers there's also
a dueling Club in the clock tower called
crossed wands run by Lucan bradleby here
you can practice your Combat on a dummy
or duel against other students sometimes
even multiple students at once some of
the school mates you encounter can
become companions who can accompany you
on your journey in various quests this
is a minor detail but something I
personally appreciate is that peeves the
Poltergeist will also be in the game
perhaps one of the biggest questions is
how classes will work while there is a
day night cycle that doesn't seem to
relate to classes classes are instead a
part of the main narrative and you'll be
learning most of your major spells and
abilities through these that said there
are also side classroom missions where
you can learn additional spells get
things you might need for outside quests
or get to know the professors better
there are talents and abilities you'll
unlock and be able to upgrade as you
progress throughout the game with Talent
points these can be gained by completing
quests and objectives and gaining
experience leveling up talents lets you
upgrade your spells plants and potions
to increase their power it's unclear how
many of these you'll get per play
through so at least from the start
you'll want to focus on leveling up ones
that suit your play style outside of
Hogwarts at a certain point the world
Beyond will open up to you and at that
moment you're free to Traverse anywhere
you like flying in the game is possible
via various mounts from the Harry Potter
World and of course brooms one of these
mounts will be hippogriffs which you can
store inside of your bag and pull out as
you will the hippogriffs ACT similar to
a horse when on the ground but they can
of course also fly another amount you
can get is a thestral which comes as
part of the dark arts pack from what I
can tell thestral seem to act just like
hippogriffs that said with both of these
at the moment we're not sure if these
are exclusive with the deluxe edition or
dark arts pack or any of those but I
kind of guess you can probably get them
through unlocks at some point in the
game but we just don't know
as far as brooms go it seems you can fly
your broom just about anywhere at least
outside however as the game takes place
in the past broom technology isn't quite
all there yet and you have a broom turbo
meter which affects your speed without
upgrades you can only use this closer to
the ground without it draining like in
the books and films hogsmeade has a shop
that sells a variety of brooms and
players will be able to customize both
the Aesthetics of their broom as well as
purchase upgrades to it
as far as traversal goes you'll also be
able to swim in the water however it's
unclear as of yet if you'll ever be able
to actually dive underneath through some
development later in the game or as part
of some Quest
while hogsmeat is of course the most
established all-wizarding Village in
burden as it's the only one and you can
visit it the team wanted to make sure
exploring the UK wasn't super Barren so
they sprinkled various hamlets
throughout the Scottish Countryside that
Wizards might live in as various wizards
live in these hamlets they help expand
the story and can also offer quests to
the player the hamlets will also have
vendors puzzles and various Secrets
throughout the game includes a day night
cycle with elements of both the open
world and school is self-changing from
fewer characters outside at night or the
school itself dying down in the evening
and various items restricted by this
cycle as you progress through the game
and the time of year changes so too does
the weather to match this so in winter
you'll see the same vibrant grassy
Fields covered in snow this won't only
affect the outer world but also the
inside of Hogwarts as well and same with
hogsmead so hopefully that means you can
have your very own cozy inside Howard's
moment during Christmas
unfortunately it's impossible to do this
sort of video without mentioning the
controversy over Hogwarts Legacy so
here's a summary JK Rowling creator of
Harry Potter has been tweeting remarks
of viewed as transphobic for the past
couple of years as such there's a strong
sentiment among the trans community that
supporting the game is supporting JK
Rowling and her views on trans people
it's also worth noting that the
development team on the game began
creating the game prior to these remarks
and are also totally divorced from it
however JK Rowling while having no
creative involvement on the game will be
benefiting from the success of the game
this is a complicated issue and we have
an article reconciling a desire to play
Hogwarts Legacy with JK Rowling's
actions written by our very own Jesse
Earl on gamespot.com which you can read
for further insight
Hogwarts Legacy releases on PS4 PS5 Xbox
One Xbox series X slash S and PC on
February 10 2023 it'll also be releasing
the Nintendo switch according to Amazon
on July 25th 2023 the deluxe edition of
the game comes with a dark arts pack
which includes a thestral mount the dark
arts cosmetic set and dark arts battle
arena for pre-ordering either edition of
the game you'll get the Onyx hippogriff
exclusive content is available with both
editions on Playstation offering you the
haunted hogsmeade shop Quest and for
pre-ordering on a PlayStation you'll
also get the Felix Felicia's potion
recipe
finally purchasing the deluxe edition on
a current gen console of PS5 Xbox series
X slash S or PC will get you 72 hours
early access to playing the game
Hogwarts Legacy is the game I always
dreamed of playing back when I was
reading the books as a kid are you
looking forward to it cautiously
optimistic or unsure of how you think it
will turn out let us know in the
comments below and I'll see you guys
next time